you know they they revel in being nasty
people
they're it's it's like all of the hate
float in one direction it's the craziest
thing yeah i i see the nastiness
component but at the same time i also
see just kind of
they they feel some sort of bizarre
warmth and ignorance you know they need
things to be like third grade level you
know the people that i talk to that just
don't really
see what's happening or they perceive it
in some way that i just i don't
understand
they want they just want to tune into
cnn for 20 minutes have their 20 minutes
and then have their talking points and
be done with it they need to be very
simple very easy and then they get on
with their lives and shout down people
that disagree with them
you know
i think we're addicted to convenience i
think the fake news is very much a form
of convenience and almost a form of
comfort to some of these people which is
really turning out to be quite the
problem because they're believing
everything they tell them so that if
they do change the rhetoric and be like
oh joe biden did this thing wrong
they're just gonna believe that hook
line and sinker two so they're clearly
not like progressly progressively
thinking through this what i was hoping
when i started to see this was that they
were starting to see that hiring someone
based on the color of their skin like
they did with camel was a terrible idea
and voting for someone like biden
against trump
terrible idea but no it's just because
they're blindly following along the
media because yeah makes them feel good
but why did they become so nasty you
know like we talked about phil to phil
defranco before there's a few other
people i know that i'm just surprised to
see become really vile people petty
tyrants um
a lot of it is why perception like the
way
that you see someone else's text is not
necessarily the way they intended it to
be seen
and so
you get people that are angry they type
something down
out of rage which is never gonna totally
you know translate what they're feeling
and then someone else reads it and has
their own feelings that they put on top
of that just a massive miscommunication
like you said you talked to your friend
but it was through text and so a lot of
communication through text i've had a
really good friend of mine i basically
cut ties with
via text because i couldn't handle the
text comments
after a while like it's but but but i
still think you
you know i get it but you're missing the
main point like
why is why are people that i know
posting
the meanest craziest things on facebook
in general
like
people who used to be normal people i
know from chicago all of a sudden are
posting things on facebook saying like f
these stupid mf i hope they all die and
burn and suffer and i'm like what the
[ __ ] happened to these people
yeah yo like there's one viral tweet
where someone's like i've seen a whole
bunch of pro-vax people celebrating the
deaths of of people who would get
vaccinated from coba and wishing their
death but i've never seen the anti-vex
people wishing the same for those who
are pro-vaccine
like what is what happened to these
people man
it's like they're they're infected with
some kind of rage
and they just want more they're addicted
to rage and anger and being mean people
hmm
someone with a uh perhaps a bit of a
spiritual religious outlook would say
that there's some sort of possession
that's happening because people are i
mean people are really they're a lot of
them i know exactly the kind of people
you're talking about and they're not
themselves and i don't know what that is
but getting to the kernel of where that
started that's really hard to unwind i
don't know i don't know what that is
demonic possession got it we'll roll
with that one
confirmed
yeah absolutely for yourself what would
put you in that state of mind
like being really mean to people yeah i
just tried not to do that i think if i
was physically uncomfortable like maybe
overweight or eating i know when i'm
physically younger even if i eat crap
and then like a day or two days later i
just have a terrible
terrible mood so that i
i don't i can't understand it man i
could not understand
posting
f all the mfr's i want them to die
i post silly garbage i tweeted out on uh
i tweeted out joe biden is the greatest
president of this or any generation then
i waited a few minutes for people to
laugh and then i said why aren't you
retweeting this
like i got i got i got uh i got no hate
i got concern
you know i got empathy
and i have disdain
i don't hate maybe cause pain it's like
um residual from trump come in and be
like the far leftists all these
jerks and hillary's like basket of
deplorables and then biden comes in and
he like arrests all these people on one
six
and what he should be doing is
letting those people go
and
commuting their sentences or their their
crimes like john hancock did with shae's
rebellion when the farmers revolted
before they signed the declaration he
realized they did it out of desperation
they didn't do it because they were evil
people so he pardoned a bunch of them
biden should pardon those people if he
wants social cohesion right now but as
long as there's this he said she said
they're villains he's an enemy
it's gonna we're gonna see it in the in
the position yeah but dude there is an
objective reality here what is that
in portland a bunch of right-wing groups
wanted to have a summer of love event
and sure you can argue they know what's
gonna happen if they have an event in
portland but they're allowed to put on a
rally where they talk and say things
antifa showed up and started throwing
gas and attacking people and then a
bunch of proud boys reacted and started
fighting back and then the media blames
the far right
certainly i think the far you know uh
the right-wing groups that are down
there don't understand that they're
being baited
but it's like what am i supposed to say
right wing group is allowed to have a
rally they're allowed to stand up on
their their their truck with a big sign
saying summer of love and the hate
and that's okay if you don't like it you
know walk away antifa has no right to
show up and throw bricks at people and
beat them and crash you know try and ram
them with cars there was a shootout and
i think the guy who got arrested was an
antifa guy i don't know for sure but he
looks more like an anti-foot guy who was
shooting two people were shooting we see
a bunch of videos a bunch of reports of
the entity people with weapons and
things like that the objective reality
is
the media will call antifa left wing and
they'll call conservatives far right and
i started thinking about this i'm like
then what's right-wing
like if if if if you're a conservative
and then you're far right then how would
the media define right wing oh i think i
know
a uh pro-universal healthcare liberal
like myself
traditional liberal i suppose more
classical liberal in a sense but they'll
call me right wing
they'll call an actual conservative far
right
they've lost the plot i don't know
what's left and right and conservative
and liberal like we look at crypto
economics and
being conservative would be to maintain
the current system of of fiscality you
know economics but we we see that it's a
broken system that's on a runaway train
to demise so it's actually
conservative to change that system to a
more conservative financial system so
whereas you would think it's liberal to
tear down the economic order and up up
install a new system it's actually very
conservative to do that because the
system is dangerous
i don't think the world the world's
yeah
yeah
you can be a liberal conservative that's
far right and far left at the same time
it's okay i'll tell you what's fine and
a centrist when i was watching i was
watching one of hassan's video because
we talked about sound figure buying the
big house and he was talking about he
said a lot of things about afghanistan
that are identical to exactly what i
said that it's a shame it's going down
this way it's good that we're getting
out and then he said but it's literally
trump's fault this is you know this is
trump's plan trump negotiated this and
my take was and it's literally biden's
fault biden changed the plan biden you
know failed like pulled pulled our
troops out of bagram air force base in
the middle of the night
and i'm like
if if someone someone super chatted this
to us if we had um
you know jack posobik or jack murphy or
steve bannon sitting down with like vosh
or or hassan they'd probably agree on
most things
and then disagree on cultural issues and
culture war issues
and so it's like
i i guess i'm just pointing out
there's a tribal need in my opinion to
blame
donald trump for everything and so
my criticism of a sign of this regard
and many on the left is it's literally
not trump's fault if you actually follow
what's happened
but it's easy to say trump negotiated
the withdrawal therefore he bears
responsibility for how this went down
because
but joe biden is literally the president
and he changed the terms of the deal
so it's like it's tribalism yeah i want
to avoid trashing biden like big problem
i was born in ohio and cleveland browns
for life cleveland browns fan because
that's my hometown and um
when the quarterback would screw up a
cleveland browns quarterback throw a few
in incompletions throw an interception
the fans would turn on the guy and be
like this guy sucks he's terrible and
then the guy would start playing worse
because his morale would be shot and
then he'd be like he's terrible get rid
of him they'd go through a quarterback
get a new quarterback he's the golden
child throws a few interceptions he's
terrible get rid of him so they
destroyed their own team by talking crap
about it if we do that with biden i'm
afraid that could happen what if the
quarterback was 78 years old and
couldn't talk
you still want to improve his morale at
that point you say get him out get him
out look i get what you're saying if i
was sitting there with you ian at a
cleveland browns game and the
quarterback was 78 and he was going
and you were like don't don't rag on a
man we got to give him a chance i'll be
like bro come on dude what are you
talking about like but it's more subtle
makes sense if he was 40 like at what
point do you watch a quarterback throw
in completions at what point do you say
he's not the guy anymore bro joe biden
wasn't the guy to begin with like he's
the commander
listen how about the quarterback of the
best team in the nfl let's try this what
if the quarterback was 78 couldn't talk
right and wasn't actually chosen by by
the team's owners or managers it was
just that the quarterback they were
gonna have the fans didn't like so they
were like just get us anybody and
they're like we got this old guy sitting
in the stands just take them because the
fans don't like that guy so it's like
what you were saying right you got a
quarterback he throws a few you know
interceptions and he and then when
people boom he starts cussing at him and
he's rude and they're like we don't want
to watch this game anymore and the
owner's like we're losing money what do
we do we need anybody anybody and
they're like just grab that 78 year old
guy who can't talk straight
and now you got people sitting there
watching and they're like dude this guy
can't play
like what do we do and you're being
you're like dude we don't want to lose
another quarterback don't rag on him and
i'm like i think we want to lose this
quarterback i think he can go home now
but you lose the whole team
when you but the vice quarterback is
even worse right the second speaker
speaker of the field is just insane
so assuming you don't have another
there's no free agents waiting to get
hired right now
then that's when morale improvement is
key because like tom brady
wasn't necessarily the best quarterback
but he was in a great organization with
massive people were behind him he had
incredible morale and thought he was
great so he kept being great he kept
fulfilling that prophecy what would
president kamala be like
she'd laugh a lot
live laugh love
maybe we'd get some video of her firing
a pistol could you imagine
could you imagine a president kamala
like already she's laughing at the
question about americans trapped in
afghanistan but could you imagine her
like sitting down with like vladimir
putin and he's like
if you do not withdraw your troops from
libya we'll fire a nuke
oh my gosh wow are these troops in
afghanistan are they like 15 000
americans left for dead were they just
left are they going to be imprisoned
like prisoners of war
well the taliban is saying like no no
we'll get the americans out and and then
there's all these these afghanis and
their families that worked with the
american troops that are still there
like i don't know how many thousands
tens of them are those people we're just
going to leave them to be incarcerated
sold into slavery have their heads cut
off like
i mean here's here's the challenge
you got to watch out for the propaganda
there's a bunch of propaganda coming out
saying like you know america don't do
this there's a like i saw one story it
said a famous afghan tick-tocker was
captured and executed by the taliban and
it seems like a lot of these stories are
preying upon western sensibilities to
make americans be like we have to go
back in and save them all and it's like
no
no
the reason the problem's this bad is
because we did this in the first place
you need to stop
just stop
unless you're pro-colonization i guess
you know and you think america should
colonize then it's like okay well then
well then you're pro-colonization
colonize mars maybe yeah well they want
to colonize afghanistan and then build a
pipeline
into europe i'm not a big fan of
colonizing on top of other people
yeah so what do you do like i don't mean
i don't mean do colonization i'm like
wha what do you do about the fact that
you've got international elites and
you've got massive corporate interests
in getting oil pipelines out of
afghanistan and they're going to fund
the politicians and the system will flow
in that direction
probably change the economics
situation i think you know remove the
fiat currency from diminish its value it
seems like what's happening
automatically how do we get the left to
be on board with like
ending the fed or about or auditing it
or something you got to make it exciting
uh my goal is to get super famous with a
hit song and then people are like yeah
whatever you say because i i'm obsessed
with you i don't worship no maybe maybe
i don't know what if we accuse the fed
of being racist yes there you go that's
a good start yeah i do like that they've
gotten woke
yeah there's like no problem no i don't
like that either
they're tactics against them yeah i'm
not a big fan no no they need now let's
be honest the federal reserve was
created by a bunch of rich white men to
uphold white supremacy there you go
mm-hmm yeah do you think they'd buy this
no it's worth a try it only works when
they're when their priests tell them
when you know when they're right the
cathedral they tried the rockefeller
rothschild keyword thing in like 2011
and that was like all the buzz is like
oh the rothschilds oh the rockefellers
and like those those families were
involved in like the creation of the
banking order and the federal reserve
and things like that but so that shock
value of like
rockefeller is gone like that came out
like 2008 that name all of a sudden was
like oh the big bad name right thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time